the medical people and or mccaffrey have
chimed in according to nfl media
mccaffrey not expected to be activated
tonight once you return to practice
though you have a three-week window
to come back from injury preserve so he
will be back sooner than later
they've got the mini buy and then they
have a trip
to kansas city looming followed by a
visit
from the tampa bay buccaneers so maybe
they're thinking let's save mccaffrey
for those games right i think they can
handle the falcons without him
i think they're better off holding the
carefree until they need him against the
chiefs chris
yeah i agreed i mean i i think that's
they should
yeah like you're saying i mean they
should be able to move the ball in the
atlanta falcons the team tonight that's
you know arguably the worst defense in
football so
you know yeah i think that this would be
one game where if you're not sure
you'd go okay hey we got lots of weapons
mike davis at running backs has been
doing a very good job yeah he's not
christian mccaffrey
but i think in their heart of hearts
that would probably be their thinking
there
he's not a hundred percent let's give
them the extra 10 days
we're playing a team that we think we
should offense shouldn't be a problem
and i don't think that it will be a
problem it shouldn't be you know the
falcons
they're a team not a great pass rush
can't play man-to-man play a lot of zone
you know and carolina's showing the
ability to either make big plays
or if you play zone and you don't want
to give up big plays they can kind of
pick you apart with their short
new orleans type passing game themselves
carolina there so
i would think they're them moving the
ball is not an issue tonight
all right let's take a look at some
props for tonight's game atlanta one and
six carolina three and four the odds
come from the
points bet sports book official sports
betting partner of nbc sports more
passing yards simple
matt ryan or teddy bridgewater who you
have
i think it'll be somewhat cool i mean
carolina's past defense is clearly the
better pass defense there's there's no
doubt about
that um but i mean atlanta has to rely
on that passing game and
you know again julio jones and matt ryan
are damn good they put up numbers
i think i'm still going to go with teddy
bridgewater here i am
you know i just think with the falcons
the way they are
and mike we've said it just about every
week and i know we don't like just you
know
talk about the panthers a lot here but
it's sneaky good weapons
on their football team and their
three-headed monster receiver
they're monsters they're really awesome
they can strike from anywhere
curtis samuel dj moore robbie anderson
are really versatile explosive weapons
on that side of the ball
let alone carolina can run the ball just
enough to keep you honest in those
things so
i'm gonna go with bridgewater uh throws
for more yards and a close one
and it's great to see teddy bridgewater
back and playing
at a high level after everything he's
been through it's it's just a given now
that he's just he's one of the i don't
know where he fits in the rankings
and i don't know if you update your top
40 on the fly during the season but
he's got to be middle of the pack to top
half right
there's a lot of damn good quarterbacks
in football right now i don't know if
i'd say top half just off the top of my
head
but i would say that he'd be towards the
top of that bottom half right
if that's fair somewhere between that 17
and 20 range
but man i don't know there's a lot of
good ones in the game right
now to say that but at some point i am
going to reshuffle and kind of
reevaluate and probably do some sort of
quarterback list just to see where
things are at because
hey you got guys like josh allen who i
had you know around 19 or
something like that and he's clearly not
19 now there's some other guys that need
to be shuffled around
i had hey brady brady at uh 15
uh he deserves to go up i mean so
there's there's a few guys i certainly
could shuffle around there
you feeling all right today i just call
like i see it mike
i just called like i said i just call i
don't play favorites i ain't got time
for that crap i'm not smart enough to be
playing those games in my head
i just gotta whatever's in there it's
got to come out of my mouth
all right uh i i'm gonna go matt ryan uh
yeah i
just it's just a gut yelling and and i
you know he'll throw a bunch of yards
he'll build a lead and then the panthers
will come back and win the game
next time hard to go gurley yeah score a
touchdown
and and a touchdown that he intends to
score
will that happen tonight for todd gurley
i i would say so
i would you know that's where carolina
if there's a weakness to their team i
mean their rotten defense is not good
their past defense is
is pretty damn good i mean they're 10th
in football and past defense
running wise yeah not so much i would
say gurley
you know yeah does get at least one
touchdown tonight in that football game
um but hey check out this with the
panthers too though
tonight if you get a chance watch their
derrick brown their first round pick you
know out of auburn the top 10 pick
he's a lot of fun to watch they they
killed it with that draft pick
you know between him and brian burns on
the edge they got some cool young guys
to watch that are they're kind of
exciting
and pop but uh i would expect gurley to
get a touchdown
build it through the draft from the
inside out it's not all that sexy on
draft night but before you know it you
end up having yourself a pretty damn
good team and
you know i don't know that the panthers
can can steal a playoff spot
this year especially with all those
great teams in the nfc west but
but man they really are building
something and they're going to be a team
to deal with as matt rule
puts his imprint on that franchise and
he's vindicating already
the money that david tepper paid him to
to come coach that team
all right most receiving yards tonight
julio jones calvin ridley
robbie anderson d.j moore here are the
points bet odds
for highest receiving yards in the game
julio plus one
70 bet 100 win 170 anderson plus 235
ridley plus 255 the long shot more
plus 300. moore had a pretty good game
against the saints on sunday that's an
intriguing bet there plus 300 on dj more
chris
that would probably be the best bet
you're right i mean
dj moore you know he's in the category
of having three rockets up his butt i
mean that's that's what he is i mean he
you know he can catch a screen and go 80
yards down the sideline you go damn he
doesn't look like he's running that fast
but nobody's
catching him and he's running away from
everybody
i'm still gonna go have to go with julio
i i guess i mean they just they always
find ways to get him the football
carolina's not a team that plays a ton
of man-to-man and dude
and like and play that scheme so i think
that lends itself to julio too
and them having enough creativity on
offense and matt ryan to where i'll go
with him even though i don't feel real
comfortable about that
yeah i uh i i you know what uh since i
don't bet i'll take the long shot
i'll say that what the hell yeah yeah we
never we never we never bring these back
and talk about them anyway but uh yeah
what the hell put
you know dj moore final answer and we'll
see how it all plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports